here's my new clinker because I'm
working these corporates you don't do
corporates do you because you're you're
filthy
even if I don't curse the content is
just - it's too much - they don't like
it it's yeah for them well I just opened
first the sign and I've been I've done
flighted for corporates last week and
I'll bombing
I have not like a Freemasons club like a
Stonecutters yeah like old white guys
like oh they all look like Dick Cheney
they got me in a headlock they're like I
you [ __ ] [ __ ] the money is really
good though the money is unbelievable
I'm rolling it on did in December so
wait so you get these corporates because
you opened for Jerry were they there I
guess that helps I think my agents like
hey we got a Seinfeld do show everywhere
and they're like oh well book him he'll
of Seinfeld issues yeah they want Ryan
Hamilton they want Tom papa then they
get mad got eight minutes on school
shootings yeah Ryan and Tom are guys who
are naturally clean guys yeah really
[ __ ] killers so you can write both of
them are you gonna start writing
material specifically for gigs like
opening for Jerry corporate gigs stuff
like that people say that but I don't
know how to do it you're right what
you're right there's a lot more money
and clean guys who were clearly
literally referenced Gaffigan a lot like
he's a great example of a guy who's a
great comic he's clean Regan yeah but
they're not trying to be clear they're
just funny as they are right lately you
can't make yourself be that right you
can't you can't it's not in you it feels
fake and false coming out of your mouth
- the whole thing's weird but I have
jokes that happen to be clean about
drinking or girlfriends or whatever but
it is not coming over like they just
know what was the first one you did so I
drove out to wilkes-barre which I'd
never heard of I go there looks bare I'm
talking old school like men's club
scotch cigar leather seats you know old
wood furniture all these portraits of
like you know
Confederate Army yeah it's like a
Cracker Barrel no but this is like high
school shitty money yes yes like these
guys hate abortion and all that [ __ ]
so I go and I'm like oh my god I had to
wear it tux you know so you're Huck yeah
this is hob telly this is high-class how
many people uh it was like a ballroom
probably like 80 people okay Hales
what's that tails on the dog tails good
so I go in and there's like one or two
women there I don't know how that works
but I go there we have lobster they make
me eat with the CEO I got to sit next to
this guy he's elbowing me is cigar
smoking my face going how about those
Asians huh they're weird you're like hey
tell me a street joke after Street joke
sit in the green room they're like now
you have to sit with the guy who's like
okay
and you're just panicking the whole time
you're [ __ ] yourself you like this
is not my element what's worse than
eating with the people before you have
to uh I literally rather be stripped
nude and beaten in front of them as they
ate dinner before I perform than sitting
there eating with them easily at least
that's funny yeah but I mean and they're
like you could tell her at the table
like this guy's a douche like he's not
even funny he's up being on aura telling
Joe he's the comedian he's not being
funny there are guys who are graded mark
Koehn is a [ __ ] great at that [ __ ]
Mark Cawley he's from the Comedy Cellar
he lives in Vegas he's like the house
emcee very funny guy naturally like he
could just
he's just that's the guy he is yeah he's
really good at that for other people you
need to have your hour of material and
then you need another 30 minutes for the
dinner yeah you gotta have your Michael
Jackson jokes and your you know Swartz
and Egger material whatever is good at
that Nick DiPaolo he's very good at
firing out jokes he's good at taking
risks like to be funny at the table like
that you got to be really good at taking
risks Nick is great at that he is good
[ __ ] even if it doesn't let you he's
not afraid to take those risks right
right I'm horrible at that I'm not great
either and I always go too far I do like
a miscarriage tomato trying to joke to
the table it didn't work
oh yeah all night did they work no
they'll bomb and I can tell they started
with like the wheels started turning
like this guy's gonna do a set this guy
sucks and they're all older right oh
yeah oh yeah just like 60 and up yeah I
mean there's some like emphysema guys in
there
did you prove them wrong once you got on
stage well I had a couple moments up top
where like they just screw me up the
guy's got a loose tie they go all right
we're gonna give it over to the the
clowns gonna come up and tap dance for
us baby here we go he's gonna [ __ ] on
all you guys he'll he's setting it up
all right who wants to get roast yeah
yeah I just got my hours I want to do it
and get out of here right so I go up and
I just go look at these [ __ ] douches
yeah you have [ __ ] animals
nothing this guy's on viagra zilch
the viagra got nothing nothing I go this
guy's I mean these guys are hard hard
asses only ahead look at this guy looks
like Colonel Sanders and the guys like
what do you mean one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM app
[Music]